الدراسه التي اجرتها كليه اداره الاعمال
في جامعه ميريلاند خلصت الى ان الموظفين
الاعلى اداء يحجبون عمدا معلوماتهم
وافكارهم حتى مخاوفهم وحتى يحين الوقت
المناسب للحديث عنها بحسب الدراسه فان
الموظفين الذين يستخدمون الصمت
الاستراتيجي ياخذون في عين الاعتبار ثلاثه
عوامل في تحديد متى وكيف يتحدثون اولا
يحددون ما اذا كان التحدث يتوافق مع اهداف
المتلقي ويلائم الوضع الحالي ثانيا يحددون
ما اذا كانوا مستعدين للتحدث او هم بحاجه
الى الانتظار حتى جمع المزيد من البيانات
المقنعه وايجاد حلول اكثر اقناعا ثالثا
ينتظرون حتى يكون المتلقي في حالته
المعرفيه الصحيحه ليس مشغولا وليس في مزاج
سيء ليكون اكثر سماعا واكثر استجابه وتخلص
الدراسه انه غالبا ما يكافئ الموظف الصامت
من قبل المدراء الذين ينظرون الى صوته على
انه اكثر قيمه للشركه والمهمه المطروحه